ich rufe auf den tagesordnungspunkt 7
und dieser tagesordnungspunkt 7 ist ein
antrag der spd fraktion in dem es um den
weiterbetrieb von atomkraftwerken geht
und sogar die wieder inbetriebnahme von
kraftwerken die wissen mindestens zum
ende des nächsten jahrzehnts ermöglicht
werden soll der hintergrund oder die
begründung der afg fraktion zu diesem
antrag ist das ziel ein blackout zu
reduzieren einem blackout gefahr zu
reduzieren welche vorrangig auf die
wetterbedingt unsichere wind und solar
einspeisung
zurückzuführen sei so formuliert es
jedenfalls die fdp fraktion deren erster
redner in dieser debatte stephen corry
sein wird während die fachpolitiker hier
im plenum noch mal die plätze tauschen
also die die sich vorrangig mit dem
thema ganztagsbetreuung
familien bildungspolitik und allem was
dazugehört beschäftigt haben verlassen
jetzt den saal die umwelt und
energiepolitiker rücken in die reihen
vor weil dann die natürliche mit ihrer
expertise gefragt sein werden in den
nächsten knapp
30 40 minuten wie diese debatte dann
dauern wird über den antrag wie gesagt
der aus der fdp-fraktion kommt
und wenn wir noch ein bisschen zeit
haben bevor die bedauerte eröffnet wird
vielleicht eine kleine information noch
vorab den tatsächlich so hat die
frankfurter allgemeine zeitung dieser
geschrieben aber ihre zeitung dieser
tage geschrieben ist das stromnetz
stabiler als gedacht die anzahl der
stromausfälle die unterbrechung dauert
ist sogar gesunken in den vergangenen
jahren details gleich noch dazu jetzt
erstmal steffen kothe
frau präsidentin sehr geehrte damen und
herren aufgrund der welt dümmsten
energiepolitik haben wir es mittlerweile
fünf minuten vor zwölf die
energieversorger schlagen alarm eon-chef
birnbaum prognostiziert dass strom
unterdeckung zur abschaltung ganzer
städte führen kann und das mit den hohen
energiepreisen die industrie aus unserem
land gejagt wird und auch der
übertragungsnetzbetreiber amprion um nur
den einen zu nennen äußert sich ähnlich
sie alle sprechen von erheblicher gefahr
für unsere stromversorgung aufgrund der
jetzigen situation das stromnetz ist
schon jetzt an seine leistungsgrenze
angekommen reserven gibt es nicht mehr
und beenden sie meine damen und herren
bitte jetzt die lebenslüge dass wir
mittelfristig ohne kohle und kernkraft
auskommen werden würden denn ihre
antwort auf die stromlücke gaskraftwerke
und stromimporte sind eine fata morgana
zusätzliche gaskraftwerke sind nicht in
sicht niemand wird sie bauen und wo soll
das gas denn eigentlich auch herkommen
wenn die bundesregierung nord stream 2
verhindern will wenn unsere naive
außenministerin mit ihrer
ungeschicklichkeit und mit ihrem
kindlichen größenwahn gegen russland und
unsere gasversorgung schließt und agiert
und damit erinnert sie eher anja größen
vielleicht wie kaiser will den zweiten
denn an eine moderne
diplomaten meine damen und herren
deutschland deutschland braucht eine
energie außenpolitik und keine energie
verhinderungspolitik mal darunter
und zum anderen punkt stromimporte wird
es in spitzenlastzeiten eben nicht gehen
können weil genau daneben auch das
ausland den strom selbst braucht und die
antwort ist deshalb naheliegend
weiterbetrieb der rentablen
kernkraftwerke
und immer mehr stimmen
sprechen auch dafür zum beispiel der
chef für volkswagen oder der ex chef von
basf um auch hier nur einige zu nennen
und die ganze welt setzt auf die nahezu
co2 freie kernenergie die niederlande
haben radien fehler eingesehen und
steigen in die kernenergie wieder ein
eine großzahl von kernkraftwerken sind
weltweit in planung und im bau und
selbst der so genannte weltklimarat geht
davon aus dass die klimaziele ohne
kernenergie gar nicht zu erreichen sind
ja viele menschen haben vorbehalte
gegenüber der kernenergie angst vor
einem super gau aber diese angst ist
unbegründet
moderne reaktorkonzepte
schließen solche katastrophen aus meine
damen und herren und teilweise ist eine
selbst erhaltene kettenreaktion
überhaupt nicht mehr notwendig
forschungsreaktoren diesbezügliche art
längst schon im bau im angeblich
technologieorientierten deutschland
jedoch leider nicht
die endlagerproblematik wird mit der
transmutation gelöst reststoffe werden
wiederverwertet heutige strahlungs zeit
von 100.000 jahren verringert sich
morgen 300 übermorgen vielleicht gar
keine mehr das ist wissenschaftlicher
technologischer fortschritt meine damen
und herren den sie verhindern wollen
die linksgrünen sie wollen co2 ausstoß
verringern wir wollen eine preiswerte
sichere stromversorgung na dann lassen
sie uns doch zusammenkommen mit moderner
und nahezu co2 freie kernenergie ist
eben beides möglich das wäre eine
intelligente das wäre eine versöhnende
und das wäre eine verantwortungsvolle
politik meine damen und herren
aber sie die sie die kernenergie
verhindern wollen sozusagen als
ewiggestrige sie werden die renaissance
der sicheren kernenergie nicht
verhindern können was sie sicherlich
verhindern dass es unser wohlstand da
sind sie weltmeister ihn zu vernichten
wir werden also kernenergie später
technologisch wieder teuer einkaufen
müssen aber seien sie mir sicher hatte
zum schluss um die kernenergie kommen
wir nicht drum herum da können sie sich
kopf stellen sie ist nicht mehr
aufzuhalten
[Applaus]
der bundestag diskutiert über einen
antrag aus der fdp fraktion zum
weiterbetrieb von atomkraftwerken
hintergrund ist ein befürchteter
blackout wenn beispielsweise wind und
solar als energiequellen nicht reichen
ist rednerin in dieser debatte ist senna
ab die aus der spd-fraktion und es ist
ihre erste rede im deutschen bundestag
präsidentin liebe kolleginnen liebe
kollegen meine damen und herren es ist
mir eine große ehre hier und heute meine
erste rede halten zu dürfen und obwohl
das erst meine erste rede hier ist hatte
ich an dieser hat sich diesen antrag
lars das im letzten monat hatte sich die
fdp fraktion in einer debatte eine
renaissance der atom und kohle energie
herbeigewünscht
und auch der heutige antrag der
fdp-fraktion basiert wie gewohnt auf
grundlegenden falschaussagen und in die
jahre gekommenen mythen atomkraft sei
unerlässlich
umweltfreundlich billig und sicher
lassen sie mich das richtig stellen
beginnen wir mit dem antrag behaupteten
blackout der stromversorgung bereits
dieser punkt ist falsch wissenschaftler
des deutschen instituts für
wirtschaftsforschung haben erst kürzlich
wieder in einer studie betont dass auch
nach abschaltung der letzten
atomkraftwerke die stromversorgung in
deutschland gesichert ist
die forscher betonen die wichtigkeit des
atomausstiegs und einen schnellen
umstieg auf erneuerbare energien
das entspricht auch den politischen
zielsetzung die wir im koalitionsvertrag
festgehalten haben dort bekennen wir uns
klipp und klar zum ausbau und zur
nutzung erneuerbarer energien
auch wird leider immer noch häufig
behauptet dass die atomenergie co2
neutral und damit umweltfreundlich sei
auch das stimmt nicht zahlreiche studien
zeigen dass bei solchen behauptung die
energie aufwendigen faktoren der
atomenergie nicht berücksichtigt werden
denn auch beim abbau von uran beim
kraftwerksbau und bei der langwierigen
endlagerung werden treibhausgase
ausgestoßen für den bau der
atomkraftwerke sind neben stahl und
zement zu dem auch edelmetalle notwendig
kurzum die branche der kernenergie ist
eines ganz sicher nicht emissionsfrei
daher sollte die kernenergie auch auf
europäischer ebene nicht als grüne
energie eingestuft werden
ein weiterer punkt der häufig falsch
dargestellt wird und auf den meine
kolleginnen aus der fraktion schon
mehrfach aufmerksam gemacht haben die
atomenergie zahlt sich nicht aus
atomkraftwerke sind und waren auf einer
vergangenheit volkswirtschaft schädigen
da die wirklichen kosten durch massive
politische subventionen abgefedert
wurden die kosten für die stromerzeugung
von wind und sonnenenergie liegen seit
jahren darunter
außerdem bleibt die kernenergie unsicher
in kernkraftwerken sind jederzeit
schwerwiegende unglücke möglich wir alle
haben die katastrophalen bilder aus
tschernobyl und fukushima noch immer
ganz verdaut deutlich vor augen von
weiteren unfällen in anderen regionen
die weit weniger mediale aufmerksamkeit
bekommen bekommen haben ganz zu
schweigen
eine große herausforderung stellen die
hochradioaktiven abfälle da die
endlagerung radioaktiver abfälle muss
für sage und schreibe eine million jahre
gewährleistet sein die damit verbundenen
risiken sind einfach nicht vorhersehbar
es ist mir zum einen unerklärlich wie
sich eine solche aufgabe vor kommenden
generationen rechtfertigen lässt zum
anderen
zum anderen trage ich sie in welchen
ihrer vorgärten hätten sie denn gern
lassen sie uns
lassen sie uns lieber zukunftsgerichtet
nach vorne schauen die atomenergie ist
ein relikt vergangener zeiten sie ist
unsicher umweltschädlich eine
unvorstellbare belastung für zukünftige
generationen und dazu noch teurer als
klimafreundliche energie
ich begrüße es sehr dass wir
ich begrüße es sehr dass wir dem
endgültigen atomausstieg in deutschland
zeitlich näher kommen dass die fdp
koalition
entschuldigung gesetzlich erledigt das
hat er in kollege sich zu einer frage
oder bemerkung gebildet wird aber
zurückgezogen danke ich begrüße es sehr
dass wir dem endgültigen atomausstieg in
deutschland zeitlich näher kommen dass
die fdp fraktionen alten zeiten
nachtrauert und dabei wissenschaftliche
erkenntnisse komplett missachtet sind
wir bereits auf diversen debatten
gewohnt wir hingegen beschäftigen uns
derweil mit dem ausbau erneuerbarer
energien und der zukunft unseres landes
beschäftigen sie sich weiterhin mit
ihren blick auf vielen dank
senna abdvali abdi war das aus der spd
fraktion mit ihrer ersten rede im
deutschen bundestag und wie es auf
großem applaus in der eigenen fraktion
gestoßen insbesondere die
schlussbemerkung in dieser debatte geht
es weiter mit jens koeppen aus der
unionsfraktion
das wort hat der kollege jens koeppen
für die cdu csu vor zu
vielen dank frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen die
transformation der energieerzeugung zu
nachhaltigen umweltfreundlichen zu
bezahlbaren und vor allen dingen aber
auch zu verfügbaren energien bleibt eine
oder die größte herausforderung der 20er
und 30er jahre auch vor dem hintergrund
dass die
dass der energiehunger weltweit ins
unermessliche steigt und vor einigen
jahren haben wir noch hier gestanden und
haben über energieeinsparungen
gesprochen davon ist weltweit überhaupt
gar nicht mehr die rede und zu dieser
mammut aufgabe kann ich uns nur erfolg
wünschen uns allen aber das funktioniert
natürlich nur wenn es einigermaßen
ideologiefrei zugeht
es geht nur wenn es auch wenn sie da
stöhnen wenn es auf faktenbasis
stattfindet auf die naturgesetzen und
nicht auf der basis von takkt vornherein
und sonst werden wir scheitern denn in
nicht einmal drei wochen
werden wir die vorletzten drei
kernkraftwerke abschalten die übrigens
zu den
weltweit besten und sichersten gehirn
es handelt sich immerhin um 4,5 gigawatt
dazu kommen noch die ersten
kohlekraftwerke so dass ab dem ersten
januar nahezu neun gigawatt fehlen
werden und es gibt bisher keine
politische antwort keine und niemanden
auf die frage wie die fehlende
leistungen ersetzt werden kann die gibt
es schlecht wenn dich nur die hoffnung
auf die nachbarn ist einfach irgendwie
zu wenig denn die frage ist werden sie
helfen können die frage können sie am
ende helfen zwar stellt der präsident
der bundesnetzagentur
jochen homann im august des jahres fest
dass die zuverlässigkeit der
stromversorgung im jahr 2020 erneut sehr
gut sei er stellt außerdem fest dass die
bisher niedrigste
ausfallzeit des jahres 2009 10 im jahr
2020 noch einmal
unterboten werden konnte und das
allgemein es keine negativen
auswirkungen auf die
versorgungssicherheit gibt in der tat
ist diese presseveröffentlichung
erstmal ermutigend sie es auch
beruhigend ein gutes signal aber die
frage ist wie lange noch wenn wir die
abfahrtszeiten sehen und die neue
bundesregierung ist in der pflicht
dieses niveau der versorgungssicherheit
in deutschland mindestens
abzusichern und es reicht eben nicht
auch kollege ab kollegen ab die
einfach nur zig tausende windräder in
deutschland zusätzlich hinzustellen oder
wertvolle agrarflächen mit solaranlagen
zuzustellen dann auch in der neuen
regierung leitet dabei in der neuen
regierung bleibt es auch dabei dass bei
dunkelheit und flaute diese halt keinen
strom produzieren und speichern
speichern kann man diese großen
strommengen auch nicht und schon gar
nicht im giga bandscheiben und auch mit
wasserstoff wird es schwierig und auch
erdgas haben sie hier und da probleme
entstehen auf kriegsfuß und ihren
koalitionsvertrag ist unmissverständlich
festgeschrieben das man am atomausstieg
in deutschland feste idealer weise den
kohleausstieg auf das jahr 2030
vorziehen will wie sie aber die ziele am
ende des tages erreichen wollen bleibt
durchgehend offen und nochmal neue
windkraftanlagen neue soll anlagen sind
kein garant für versorgungssicherheit
sie können immer nur teil einer lösung
sein nur teil einer lösung egal wie viel
die fläche zugestellt wird und da können
sie auch noch so laut scheinen da muss
schon mehr kommen die bürger warten
konkrete antworten wie die
versorgungssicherheit
mindestens auf dem jetzigen eu
abgesichert werden sollen sonst bleibt
ihr ganzer koalitionsvertrag in diesem
kontext lediglich grüne makulatur
erzielen danken
sagt wir uns köpfen aus der
unionsfraktion in einer debatte die sich
mit dem weiterbetrieb von
atomkraftwerken
beschäftigt dazu noch die information
spätestens ende letzten jahres soll das
letzte atomkraftwerk in deutschland
abgeschaltet sein und dann wird der
strombedarf was die inländische
produktion angeht zum einen noch aus den
laufenden kohlekraftwerken gespeist
werden als auch aus erneuerbaren
energien und ob das an der einen oder
anderen stelle reicht dass wir hier und
da bezweifelt nächster gegner ist der
neue umweltpolitische sprecher der
fraktion bündnis 90/die grünen stefan
wenzel
sehr geehrte damen und herren sehr
geehrte abgeordnete vor gut zehn jahren
hat der ehemalige
bundesumweltminister professor klaus
töpfer den bericht der ethikkommission
an die bundesregierung übergeben
frau ministerin rauch bundeskanzlerin
merkel und herr bundesminister rösler
haben diesen bericht damals entgegen
genommen das ist ja zehn jahre her und
dieser bericht hat das ende der
atomenergie in deutschland besiegelt
meine damen und herren gestern mittag
habe ich versucht den antrag zu bekommen
der fraktion der fft der lach gestern
mittag noch nicht vor offenbar scheint
es da bei ihnen
ein bisschen ein bisschen probleme zu
geben zehn jahre wussten sie was kommt
und einen tag vor dieser debatte hatten
sie ihren antrag noch nicht fertig meine
damen und herren das spricht für sich
vor zehn
jahren
vor zehn jahren meine damen und herren
traf man
überzeugte
atomphysiker die sichtlich geschockt
waren nachdem sie gesehen haben was in
fukushima passiert ist und die auch ganz
persönlich dazu sehr eindrucksvoll
berichtet haben dass sie sich so was
schlicht und einfach nicht habe
vorstellen können zumal in allen studien
die es damals gab von erasmus studien
bis zu vielen anderen solche ereignisse
kategorisch ausgeschlossen wurden sie
wurden einfach schlicht und einfach für
nicht möglich gehalten und dann kam der
bericht der ethikkommission
wissenschaftsbasierte da waren sehr gute
sehr renommierte wissenschaftlerinnen
und wissenschaftler dabei anerkannte
persönlichkeiten der bundesrepublik
deutschland energiepolitiker und die
haben dann einen bericht vorgelegt meine
damen und herren deutschlands
energiewende ein gemeinschaftswerk für
deutschlands zukunft und dort hieß es
zum atomstrom gibt es alternativen die
allesamt weniger risiken aufweisen
allesamt weniger risiken aufweisen und
man hat dann entschieden sieben
atomkraftwerke sofort abzuschalten nicht
mehr ans netz zu gehen zu lassen und
krümmel auch nicht meine damen und
herren das ist jetzt zehn jahre her und
wichtig war der begriff
gemeinschaftswerk das sage ich auch mit
blick auf herrn können weil das ist
nämlich ein ganz entscheidender begriff
dass wir das auch in zukunft als
gemeinschaftswerk betreiben um hier
unsere energieversorgung sicher
umweltfreundlich und klimafreundlich zu
machen und natürlich
natürlich steht die
versorgungssicherheit dabei an erster
stelle mittlerweile haben wir 50 prozent
erneuerbaren strom aus einer heimischen
energiequellen nämlich den erneuerbaren
meine damen und herren teilweise wir
haben bundesländer die decken
mittlerweile schon 90 prozent des
verbrauchs ab mit erneuerbaren energien
jetzt kommen wärme verkehr und industrie
dran dafür hat die ampelkoalition pläne
vorgelegt die netzbetreiber haben in den
letzten jahren massiv investiert und sie
haben die versorgungssicherheit ständig
verbessert die ausfälle im netz sind
global gesehen die geringsten und jetzt
kommt mit dem projekt wie dispatch 20
noch eine steigerung da geht es sehr
wohl um effizienz herr köpfen da geht es
um effizienz beim betreiben des netzes
da geht es aber auch an anderen stellen
um beispielsweise eine investition in
elektromobilität ist auch eine
investition in energieeffizienz um eine
damen
und wenn ich dann den antrag ihrer
fraktion hier auf der rechten seite lese
meine damen und herren sie verbreiten
märchen da wird schon eine art von
atommüll verbrennung gesprochen man will
atommüll mit
halbwertszeiten von über einer million
jahren quasi verbrennen da lesen sie mal
nach die gutachten der endlager
kommission zur transmutation so das ist
damals sehr dass es damals sehr
gründlich untersucht worden und das ist
von allen seiten in bausch und bogen
verworfen worden meine damen und herren
das projekt können sie vergessen sie
verbreiten die märchen versuchen den
leuten weismachen man könnte etwas tun
was technisch physikalisch nicht möglich
ist ziehen sie an antrag zurück wir
werden ihnen ansonsten ablehnen vielen
dank fürs zuhören
stefan wenzel war das neu im bundestag
aber auch der neue umweltpolitische
sprecher der fraktion bündnis 90/die
grünen und von 2013 bis 2017 war er
umweltminister in niedersachsen falls
dem oder der ein oder anderen von ihnen
das gesicht bekannt vorgekommen sein
sollte
eine informelle verabredung zumindest
gibt dass wir die erste rede
möglichst nicht unterbrechen ich muss
trotzdem jetzt fragen herr abgeordneter
hilfe stehen sie jetzt auf eine
intervention
gut dann sage ich einfach den
abgeordneten wenzel schon er hat die
möglichkeit in dieser zeit darüber
nachzudenken ob er dann noch einmal
redezeit im sinne einer erwiderung
beanspruchen möchte der abgeordnete
hatte
vielen dank präsidentin dass die kurze
information zu lassen ich kenne diese
informelle vereinbarung allerdings
erschien der redner so rhetorisch gut
drauf und sicher dass ich dann mich doch
entschlossen hatte diese zwischen frage
zu stellen sie haben vorhin angegeben
dass 50%
sozusagen aus erneuerbaren energien
kommen ich würde ihnen empfehlen ab und
zu mal dass acura meter aufzurufen und
dann sage ich ihnen mal was hier steht
um 11 uhr 30 gibt dass es wird immer
angezeigt wie viel strom wird gerade
produziert aus welchen energiequellen
und da steht für 11 30 insgesamt also
strom aus wind und sonne ich schätze mal
circa kann man nicht genau erkennt 18 gb
und verbraucht wurde zu diesem zeitpunkt
73 gigabyte
18 gegner haben ihre hochgelegten
regenerativer energien produziert und
73 haben wir gebraucht wo soll das
herkommen wenn sie die kernkraftwerke
abschalten wenn sie die kohlekraftwerke
abschalten wenn sie keine kraftwerke
bauen weil die lok stream 2 verhindern
einfach nur mal packten ich möchte es
gerne von ihnen wissen aber ich kann mir
vorstellen dass sie diese antwort nicht
beratern
kollege wenzel sie haben das wort zur
erwiderung
vielen dank sehr geehrte frau
präsidentin sehr geehrte damen und
herren ich würde gern kurz stellung
nehmen ich würde ihn schlicht und
einfach empfehlen beispielsweise war
beim fraunhofer-institut sich ein paar
charts anzugucken sich ein paar quellen
an zu gucken wo man über die gesamten
durchschnittswerte eines jahres hinweg
die unterschiedlichen analysen beim
stromverbrauch dargestellt werden und
natürlich sieht man dort dass wir noch
einen ordentlichen weg vor uns haben
aber es ist ohne zweifel möglich die
restlichen atomkraftwerke abzuschalten
und wir werden die durch erneuerbare
energien ersetzen und wir werden die
versorgungssicherheit auf extrem hohem
niveau auch in zukunft gewährleisten
von stefan wenzel mit einer erwiderung
auf eine kurze intervention des hfg
abgeordneten hilse der sich von einer
sonder tribüne gemeldet hat die formal
zum plenarsaal gehört aber da oben
sitzen halt die mdb die über ebenso oder
genesenen status keine auskunft geben
wollen und hier geht es weiter mit ralph
lenkert aus der linksfraktion
umweltpolitischer sprecher
lobbyisten behaupten atomkraft sei
sicher nur alle 10.000 betriebsjahre
würde ein schwerer unfall passieren bei
4 100 kernreaktoren weltweit passiert
also alle 25 jahre statistik ein
super-gau stimmt
1979 harrisburg
1986 tschernobyl
2011 fukushima und nun hat die ard die
echt blöde idee
atomkraftwerke die für 40 jahre geplant
war 50 jahre und länger laufen lassen zu
wollen liebe bürgerinnen und bürger für
ein 40-jähriges auto bekommen sie kaum
ersatzteilen die wartung wird
schwieriger und teurer und die technik
entspricht nicht mehr dem aktuellen
stand
als techniker bei sich bei alten
atommeilern ist das nicht anders mit
jedem pc zu ersteigen es kostet und das
ausfallrisiko geht nach oben
und die gefahr dass nach kleinen
staffeln und einer notabschaltung
einblick und provoziert wird wächst
enorm
deshalb jetzt ein paar wirklich gute
ideen für mehr versorgungssicherheit
die linke fordert energiespeicher
damit der überschussstrom von wind und
solar für später aufgehoben werden kann
wir fordern elektrolyse und
biogasanlagen die direkt in das
vorhandene gasnetz einspeisen
damit zukünftige reservekraftwerke
dieses erneuerbare gas in strom und
wärme bei dunkel flotten umwandeln und
die linke stärkte stadtwerke denn die
koordinierung vor ort erzeugung
verteilung und speicherung von energie
das senkt das risiko von deutschland
beiden black ops und schafft regionale
wertschöpfung und übrigens braucht das
weniger stark stromtrassen und erst
recht keine atomkraftwerke
liebe bürgerinnen und bürger ohne abo
ohne subvention wurde atomstrom 20 cent
die kilowattstunde kosten wind und
solarstrom kann man für unter 7 cent
produzieren also atomkraftwerke und
starkstrom kreisen steigern die gewinne
der energiekonzerne aber leider auch die
private rechnung von uns allen und
schützen nicht vor blackouts deshalb
konnte die linke ein nein zu akw s und
ein nein zur überbordenden netzausbau
vielen dank
stefan nach pardon ralph lenkert aus der
linksfraktion sie sehen das präsidium
hat gewechselt für jetzt vizepräsidentin
aydan özoguz dem bundestag vor und in
dieser in diesem bundestag sehen wir
jetzt lukas köhler aus der fdp-fraktion
letzte legislaturperiode
klimapolitischer sprecher in dieser ist
er zum stellvertretenden
fraktionsvorsitzenden aufgestiegen
sehr geehrte frau präsident sind meine
lieben kolleginnen und kollegen der
antrag der vorliegt ist ich finde es
viele erreichen sich dünn aber er ist
vor allen dingen in der sache falsch sie
gehen von zwei grundrissen von zwei
grundideen aus warum wir in deutschland
die kernkraft verlängern sollten die
eine ist wir brauchen die kernkraft vor
zur versorgungssicherheit die zweite
grund prämisse ist dass kernkraft für
günstige stromversorgung
beides ist de facto und an den
unterschiedlichsten stellen widerlegt
worden diese nationale diese nation
diese passten nationalistische die ich
hier in deutschland jetzt eine
technologie zu verlängern in der die
leute in der die unternehmen schon lange
nicht mehr investieren in denen wir gar
nicht mehr dafür sorgen können dass sie
wirtschaftlich betrieben werden können
ist völlig absurd es ist völlig absurd
weil wir schon lange schon lange in
deutschland sehen dass wir aus der
atomenergie aussteigen und auch
natürlich die unternehmen nicht mehr
weiter investiert das heißt rein
pragmatisch und es geht bei
energiepolitik ist meiner sicht ganz
ganz viel um die idee des pragmatismus
rein pragmatisch wird es nicht
funktionieren
der zweite punkt sie frage des preises
die frage des preises energie und wir
sehen in den internationalen märkten
dass immer dann wenn wir neue
atomkraftwerke wie zb hinkley point
bauen dass diese atomkraft extrem teuer
wird und gegenüber gegenüber
erneuerbaren energien im abbild immer
sie müssen hinkley point mit 10 cent
kilowattstunde
absichern und haben bauen solarparks in
portugal für 1 cent da haben sie immer
noch immer noch 9 cent zur verfügung um
speicher zu nutzen um wasserstoff zu
produzieren um ja auch gaskraftwerke mit
erneuerbarer energie zu versorgen weil
das ist das ziel der
versorgungssicherheit
die idee die hinter
atomenergie steht ist hat einen
sozialistischen grundzug denn sie
verlagern die risiken der atomenergie
auf die allgemeinheit sie können die
risiken der atomenergie nur über den
staat absichert und das meine damen und
herren ist genau der falsche weg in der
versorgung mit glätte
diese kombination aus einem reinen
nationalen interesse und der verlagerung
der risiken der verschiebung der risiken
auf die allgemeinheit ist eine idee die
aus einer vergangenen zeit stammt meine
damen herren und ich glaube nicht dass
sie uns gut tut in keinerlei hinsicht
der punkt der versorgungssicherheit wird
in deutschland über eine hohes maß an
flexibilität ablehnt wir brauchen dazu
speicher
speicher definieren speicher bauen wir
und das prinzip der elektrolyse sollten
sie selbst sie im chemie unterricht
gelernt haben
wir werden über wasserstoff in zukunft
deutschland versorgungssicher macht und
das ziel der versorgungssicherheit ist
gegeben wir werden den weg über gas
geben müssen er hat das wird eine
übergangstechnologie sein aber dieser
weg ist vorgezeichnet aber meine damen
und herren ich finde es ist eine sehr
rückwärtsgewandte debatte die sie uns
hier auf gezwungen haben sie haben eine
rückwärtsgewandte debatten deswegen auch
gemacht weil sie irgendwie alte
technologien verlängern die zukunft die
zukunft um die es geht geht in die
richtung der frage wie versorgen wir den
globalen sie mit versorgungssicherheit
vor allen dingen aber wer wird den
globalen süden mit erneuerbarer
günstiger energie versorgt und das ist
die aufgabe von der diese
bundesregierung wir müssen beweisen dass
wir ein energiesystem schaffen das
günstige co2 100 rate energieversorgung
und der einzige weg den das den wir
beschreiten können mit deutscher
technologie in anderen ländern dafür zu
sorgen dass wir klimaschutz gemeinsam
als globale herausforderung verstehen
und umsetzen ist der weg über die
kombination aus erneuerbaren energien
und wasserstoff und das können wir
beweisen wenn wir das nicht beweisen in
zukunft dann werden wir keinen
klimaschutz machen und deswegen meine
damen und herren müssen wir uns dafür
anstrengen dass dieser weg in zukunft
gegangen würden dafür stieg neue
bundesregierung darauf läuft
soweit der neue stellvertretende
vorsitzende der fdp-fraktion lukas
kohler wie gesagt letzte
legislaturperiode
klimapolitischer sprecher und es kommt
wiederum jemand mit einer neuen funktion
nämlich andreas lenz aus der
unionsfraktion nicht neu im parlament
aber neu als sprecher für klimaschutz
und energie
und herren liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen wir werden heute an einen
antrag der alte und der antrag ist
wieder besonders neu noch besonders
originell aber das sind wir ja gewöhnt
es handelt sich um eine ansammlung von
fehlinformationen von irrtümern aber
auch von falschinformationen und dass
deshalb werden wir den antrag
entsprechend ablehnen das thema
atomstrom wird unterschiedlich
unterschiedlich gesehen unterschiedlich
diskutiert und auch unterschiedlich
bewertet auch auf europäischer ebene das
muss man ja schlicht konstatieren aber
zum einen wollen die deutschen
kraftwerksbetreiber diese technologie im
moment nicht und zum anderen ist auch
klar atomstrom ist eben nicht die
günstigste form der energieerzeugung und
übrigens ist es auch so dass kein
versicherungsunternehmen der welt
atomkraftwerke versichert
marktwirtschaft sieht anders aus liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
und daher überlegt sich für den moment
die diskussion aber ich möchte schon
auch sagen dass das thema forschung und
entwicklung auch in diesen themenbereich
von uns offen gesehen und unterstützt
wird unter der unionsgeführten
bundesregierung gegen der ausbau der
erneuerbaren massiv voran wir stehen bei
annähernd 50 prozent
erneuerbare im strombereich natürlich
immer natürlich immer im schnitt und wir
haben die klimaschutzziele 2020 erreicht
40 prozent weniger co2 ausstoß im
vergleich zu 1990 und wir haben
wir haben das wirtschaftswachstum vom
ressourcenverbrauch entkoppelt und man
muss hier auch mal konstatieren das
waren wir und es war nicht viel liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
die union hat eine nationale wasserstoff
strategie initiiert diese muss jetzt
natürlich weitergedacht werden stichwort
delegierter rechts aktien die
energiewende zu ende gedacht wird nicht
nur in deutschland stattfinden es geht
internationale partnerschaften für die
erzeugung von power tricks von
synthetischen kraftstoffen aber eben
auch von wasserstoff zu schmieden wir
werden auch zukünftig nicht energie
autark in deutschland sein können wir
müssen natürlich nationale potenziale
geben aber wir müssen auch global denken
deutschland hat im internationalen
vergleich mit die höchsten strom und
energiekosten dass estland schließlich
natürlich gift für den
produktionsstandort und es ist natürlich
auch eine soziale frage und wir wollten
schon in der letzten legislatur die
eeg-umlage abschaffen das ging leiter
damals mit dem
bundesfinanzminister nicht und wir
werden ganz genau schauen
wir werden ganz genau schauen ob und wie
sie die umlage jetzt auch tatsächlich
abschaffen wollen und sie wollen ja
einiges jetzt in der ampelkoalition wenn
man den koalitionsvertrag auch liest
aber das wollen alleine das wird nicht
reichen wir werden auch ganz genau
schauen ob sie und wie sie die dinge
auch erreichen werden liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen und wir werden sie wir
werden die an der realität messen meine
sehr geehrten damen und herren
versorgungs versorgungssicherheit ist
wichtig das thema sollte auch gesetzlich
entsprechend definiert auch and
gesetzlich geregelt werden wenn wir aus
atomen aus kohle aussteigen brauchen wir
ersatz kapazitäten die scheiben zwar im
koalitionsvertrag
dass sie gas kraftwerke errichten wollen
aber die wachsen natürlich nicht einfach
aus dem boden wir brauchen für diese
neuen kraftwerke anreiz wir brauchen
investitionssicherheit wir brauchen
letzten endes auch planungssicherheit
mit einem kapazitäts markt und sie
müssen außer denen in ihrer koalition
ihr verhältnis zur stunde 2 immer noch
klären dann gibt es völlig
unterschiedliche wahrnehmungen oder auch
widersprüchliche aussagen auch daran
werden wir sie messen klar ist für uns
wir brauchen weiterhin innovationen wir
brauchen technik wir brauchen anreize
wir brauchen einen massiven ausbau der
erneuerbaren energien aber eben auch
versorgungssicherheit und die
bezahlbarkeit und dafür stehen wir in
dem sinne herzlichen dank
andreas lenz aus der unionsfraktion bei
der frau letzte redner in der debatte zu
einem antrag der fdp fraktion zum
weiterbetrieb von atomkraftwerken
letzter redner wird jakob blankenburg
sein er ist aktuell der jüngste
abgeordnete in der
spd-fraktion seine erste rede und er
kommt übrigens aus dem landkreis
lüchow-dannenberg wo es sich
bekanntermaßen auch die gemeinde
gorleben mit dem atommüll zwischenlager
gibt die 2011 ihren letzten
castortransport in
atomkraftwerke abgeschaltet und damit
endet auch ein stück deutscher
geschichte eine geschichte die mit dem
glauben an technik und fortschritt
begann und im erbitterten widerstand von
teilen der bevölkerung mündete eine
geschichte die eigentlich schon viel
früher hätte beendet werden sollen
und dann doch weiter erzählt wurde eine
geschichte an deren ende eine menge hoch
radioaktiver müll stehen wird man kann
diese geschichte aus verschiedenen
perspektiven erzählen aber das fazit das
ist immer das gleiche es ist gut dass
wir aus der atomenergie aussteigen und
das haben wir auch im koalitionsvertrag
bekräftigt
die afg schlägt nun alle jahre wieder
vor den weiterbetrieb der kernkraftwerke
zu ermöglichen die geschichte der
deutschen atomkraft soll nach dem willen
der afg nicht enden sie begründet das
mit der angeblichen
versorgungssicherheit und der
vermeintlichen umweltfreundlichkeit aber
lieber afd mit verlaub das ist unsinn
der anteil der atomkraft am
primärenergieverbrauch ist gering sie
kann deshalb keinen erwähnenswerten
beitrag zum erreichen der klimaziele
leisten
eine abschaltung der akw es wird auch
nicht zum blackout führen wie wir heute
auch schon von meinen vorrednerin gut
ausgeführte bekommen haben
atomkraft ist unglaublich teuer und vor
allem wenn man die kosten für zwischen
und endlagerung mit einrechnet und jeder
cent der in atomkraft inhalt investiert
wird fehlt beim ausbau der erneuerbaren
energien
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen das
wendland mein wahlkreis ist ganz
besonders eng mit der geschichte der
atomenergie verbunden in gorleben sollte
ein atomares endlager entstehen sie alle
kennen die bilder von polizei
hundertschaften von großdemonstrationen
von menschen die sich dann gleise ketten
im wendland steht heute noch das anti
atomkraft iks in jedem zweiten vorgarten
das misstrauen das gefühl der ohnmacht
haben die menschen hier geprägt die
atomkraft und die frage der atomaren
endlagerung war lange zeit ein zentrales
konfliktfeld im wendland und im ganzen
land mit dem reaktorunglück in fukushima
hat dieses haus und parteiübergreifenden
konsens endgültig den ausstieg aus der
atomenergie beschlossen absolut zurecht
der beschluss zum ausstieg aus der
atomkraft hat konfliktlinien befriedet
er hat dafür gesorgt dass sich
unterschiedliche gesellschaftliche und
politische gruppen an einen tisch setzen
konnten die endlagersuche erfolgt nun
nach wissenschaftlichen kriterien sie
wird ergebnisoffen durchgeführt und die
bevölkerung wird in die suche
miteinbezogen
am ende dieser suche wird es einen
standort für radioaktiven müll in
deutschland gehen bis zu 1900 castoren
mit hochradioaktiven abfällen werden
dort lagern denn der müll bleibt auch
dann wenn wir über die zivile nutzung
der atomkraft in deutschland nur noch in
den geschichtsbüchern lesen können ich
kann nur sagen jeder einzelne tag den
ein akw weiterläuft wird mehr atommüll
produziert jeder tag den die
atomkraftwerke in deutschland nach 2022
weiterlaufen werden ist ein tag zu viel
und dieser meinung dieser meinung sind
im übrigen nicht nur die kolleginnen und
kollegen der demokratischen fraktion und
ich selbst die betreiber der sechs noch
laufenden atomkraftwerke stimmen uns zu
ich zitiere kurz vor abschalten in
deutschland eine debatte darüber zu
starten ob kernkraftwerke noch einen
wichtigen beitrag zum klimaschutz
leisten ist befremdlich sagte zum
beispiel am 11 november diesen jahres
der von ihnen zitierte er und cher
birnbaum dem handelsblatt
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
wir haben nur wenige jahrzehnte
atomkraft genutzt meine generation und
alle folgenden haben kaum oder gar nicht
davon profitiert mit dem atommüll müssen
wir trotzdem leben das können wir nicht
mehr ändern in sachen strom wird es in
unserem land aber eine neue geschichte
geschrieben die akw es werden
geschlossen die enklave endlagerung ist
auf dem weg erneuerbare energien werden
enorm ausgebaut das ist das was wir in
sachen versorgungssicherheit brauchen
deshalb gehen wir den antrag der afg ab
vielen dank
um mit der ersten rede von jobst jakob
blankenburg endet dieser
tagesordnungspunkt über den antrag der
fdp wird direkt abgestimmt der afg auf
drucksache 274 mit dem titel black out
verhindern weiterbetrieb der
kernkraftwerke
ermöglichen wer stimmt für diesen antrag
das ist die afg fraktion wäre stimmt
dagegen
das sind alle übrigen fraktionen wer
enthält sich dann ist der antrag
abgelehnt